dauchet une demande cette reconnaissance
était une demande de la douma d'état
aujourd'hui mais aussi des présidents
des républiques de donetsk et de
lougansk la demande elle avait déjà et a
fait 7 et le 15 février dernier vladimir
poutine prenait à ce moment là la mise
en oeuvre des accords de minsk pour
régler cette crise mais qu'est ce qui a
changé depuis les accords de minsk
pourquoi sont ils morts aujourd'hui
finalement écouté des accords demi ce
que n'ont pas été
validés mise en oeuvre par pas remis par
l'ukraine donc
on nous sommes arrivés non pas un point
de non retour mais nous venons de
franchir une étape ne sont montés d'un
cran dans
l'escaladé on a au fond eux les les
adversaires de la russie de la
fédération de russie ne peuvent s'en
prendre qu'à eux mêmes puisqu'ils ont
poussé ils ont poussé monsieur poutine à
prendre cette décision
lui même était l'objet de demandes
pressantes part de la part d'un certain
nombre de membres de la douma d'état et
à la fin des fins monsieur poutine qui a
freiné qui a freiné a bien fallu se
rendre compte se rendre compte qu'il
s'est être un passage obligé et
d'ailleurs je m'arrête ici mais on peut
on pourrait égrainer la liste des
erreurs commises par kiev depuis le
départ ont si bien que le donbass ne
demandait que le respect de son identité
linguistique et des choses se sont
dégradées face aux côtés intraitable dès
des ukrainiens eux mêmes alors